hi I'm Ryan and I'm gonna be watching
the trailer for the amazing spider-man 2
[ __ ] yeah whoa
oh [ __ ] every day I wake up knowing that
the more people I try to save I will
follow should its transplant it's just a
matter of time before I face those with
more power
I can overcome
[Music]
I'm so sorry I'm late
I had a traffic thing your traffic Jim
have anything to do with being I don't
know shot at my machine guns very
helpful you're gonna want to see us
Oscar did you marry a homosexual why
isn't that the question of the day the
truth does Tiffany my name is Richard
Parker I have discovered what Oscorp was
to use my research for I have a
responsibility to protect the world from
what I'm not there
what is office the future literally can
change the world what about Peter not
everyone has a happy ending James Bowman
speaker the new Peter
I made a choice right this is not all
about choices
[Music]
[Applause]
damn it's better than the first one
IMAX I'm definitely going man and emma
stone to a bigger I'd watch Andrew
Garfield and Emma Stone banging each
other I think we'd all watch that